-Joe Biden met Russian
President Vladimir Putin
face-to-face for the first time
in his presidency
during a summit in Geneva.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
♪♪
Biden has been on the first
major international trip
of his presidency,
meeting with leaders
of the G7 and NATO
and trying to restore
our relationship with key allies
who seemed excited to have
a U.S. President
interested in global cooperation
on issues
like climate and the pandemic,
as opposed to the last guy
who openly professed
his admiration for dictators.
But when it came time
to meet with a U.S. ally,
he always had
the bummed-out look of a guy
who was in a waiting room
at a urologist's office.
Looks like he should be flipping
through an old "Golf Digest,"
getting mad whenever
someone else's name is called.
"Okay, he definitely came in
after me. This is bull[bleep]"
Trump was always visibly
thrilled to meet with Putin
or Mohammed bin Salman
or Kim Jong-un.
But then when he had to sit down
with Angela Merkel,
he looked like he got dragged
into the principal's office
for setting some goats loose
in the parking lot
on senior prank day.
"Do you know how much
property damage you caused?"
"But it was all in good fun."
"You don't even go
to this school."
"That's all part
of the prank, man."
U.S. allies seem to be
enjoying the change of pace.
And, in particular, Biden really
seems to be chumming it up
with French President
Emmanuel Macron,
meeting one-on-one with him
in wicker chairs by the beach
like they were doing press
for one of those
Nicole Kidman
seaside murder dramas,
talking intensely
as other G7 leaders
walked alongside them.
And chatting again later
during a more informal
gathering,
Macron looks like
he's reenacting
all the weird [bleep]
Trump ever did to him.
"And then he brushed dandruff
off my shoulder
and asked me if I could show him
where they make
the French's mustard."
Thanks to their age difference,
Biden looks like a dad
giving his adult son
financial advice.
"You got to start saving
for retirement now.
Get a Roth IRA.
How much did you spend
on this suit?
I got a guy who will
make you one for 50 bucks.
He just cuts it out
of the carpet in his house."
But, of course,
the biggest test so far,
just how much American
leadership on the world stage
has changed in the post-Trump
era, came today
when Biden met Putin
face-to-face.
Ahead of the meeting,
Biden declared that he'd be
holding a solo press conference
rather than doing one
with Putin,
a change from the Trump years.
-The bottom line is that I think
the best way to deal with this
is for he and I to meet,
he and I to have our discussion.
I know you don't doubt that
I'll be very straightforward
[laughs] with him
about our concerns.
And I will make clear my view
of how that meeting turned out.
And he'll make clear, from his
perspective, how it turned out.
But I don't want
to get into being diverted
by, "Did they shake hands?
How far -- Who talked the most?"
-First of all, we know
who'd do most of the talking.
It's Biden.
In any situation, it's Biden.
If Biden went on a tour
of the Sistine Chapel
where they tell you not to talk,
he'd make it five seconds
before saying,
"How the hell
do you paint a ceiling
without it dripping
all over you?
I got to get
the number of their guy.
What? I'm not talking.
I'm asking a question."
Also, Putin doesn't talk.
He glares.
Biden would be 10 minutes
into an answer on sanctions
while Putin just
sits there silently,
either hatching a plan
for world domination
or rehearsing judo moves
in his head.
"Gonna do some jogging with
the knees low -- low knees --
and then trot, trot, trot
and then a roll-over
and then hop up
and then go into a slow roll
like a baby, back to my feet.
Slow roll like a baby,
back to my feet.
And then maybe a little
prance, prance, prance.
Prance and dance.
And I'm going to flip you
to the ground like boom.
And that is how that will go."
[ Laughter ]
Of course, no one even asked
questions about handshakes
or talking during Trump's
meeting with Putin in Helsinki,
given that there were much
stranger moments to dissect,
like when Putin gave Trump
a soccer ball
and Trump definitely looked like
he didn't know what it was.
"I guess in Russia, they bowl
without the finger holes."
Back then, the questions
came from Trump himself,
and they were a little more
along the lines of crazy old man
waiting for his check
at a diner.
-Where is the server?
I want to know,
where is the server,
and what is the server saying?
I really do want
to see the server.
What happened to the server?
-Remember that, when the
President of the United States
used a press conference
with the leader
of a foreign adversary
to complain in length
about an insane conspiracy
theory involving a server?
He sounded like he was waiting
for his jalapeño poppers
at Applebee's.
"I ordered them 10 minutes ago.
Where is the server?
I need my poppers.
I got to get my pop on."
And, you know, honestly,
side note here --
I do think that would be
a great catchphrase
for an Applebee's commercial.
I mean, can you picture a guy,
settles into a table,
orders a steaming-hot plate
of jalapeño poppers,
then he looks straight down the
barrel of the camera and says,
"I got to get my pop on"?
It's certainly much better than
"eatin' good
in the neighborhood."
Just because it rhymes,
it doesn't mean it makes sense.
No one actually
has an Applebee's
in their neighborhood.
At the very least,
it should be "eatin' good
by the off-ramp."
You know, last I checked,
you can't buy a house
in a cozy little cul-de-sac
in suburban New Jersey
that just happens to be
right next to an Applebee's.
Look, the problem is, though,
Applebee's execs keep telling me
my slogan doesn't work
because they don't have
jalapeño poppers
and that I should talk
to Arby's.
And, honestly, I don't know the
difference between those two.
I live in Manhattan.
My local neighborhood restaurant
is a bodega where you can get
an egg and cheese
on a roll with a side
of AA batteries
and a single roll of Charmin.
Now, that's eatin' good
in the neighborhood.
What was I saying?
Oh, Biden and Putin.
Anyway, Biden was clearly aware
of the potential perils
of a joint press conference
with Putin.
For one thing, he apparently
consulted some Russia experts
who worked for Trump back then
and were horrified by that
press conference in Helsinki.
-Tonight, Axios reporting
the team preparing the President
for the Putin meeting
includes a group
of outside Russia experts,
including former
Trump officials.
Said to be among the dozen
or so participants --
Fiona Hill, the former
Trump National Security Council
official
who testified at his
first impeachment trial.
-I just want to read something
that you told the BBC
about the Trump-Putin
press conferences in Helsinki.
And you said this --
You said,
"My initial thought was just,
'How can I end this?'"
Did you seriously consider
that it was that bad?
-I did seriously think about it.
I, first of all, you know,
looked around
to see if there was
a fire alarm.
But, you know, we were
in a rather grand building
attached to the presidential
palace of the Finnish president,
who had lent it to us
for the occasion.
And I couldn't see anything
that resembled a fire alarm.
-It would take more than
a fire alarm to drown out Trump.
The guy spent four years
giving press conferences
next to a whirring
helicopter blade.
Second, buildings in Finland
don't have fire alarms?
Do they just, what,
wait for a brigade of gnomes
to come down from the mountains
and put the fire out with magic?
"I heard there was a fire.
Don't worry.
I'll summon a giant wave
with my mystical power!
And if that doesn't work, I'll
smother it with my beard."
Yeah, I think I had it.
That's how bad
the Trump-Putin summit was.
So Biden has been trying
to learn the lessons
of that disaster
and avoid any pitfalls.
For example, you might remember
this infamous moment
when Trump seemed
to take Putin at his word
that Russia had nothing to do
with election hacking,
then had to walk it back with
an absolutely absurd excuse.
-I have President Putin.
He just said it's not Russia.
I will say this -- I don't see
any reason why it would be.
In a key sentence in my remarks,
I said the word "would"
instead of "wouldn't."
The sentence should have been,
"I don't see any reason
why I wouldn't
or why it wouldn't be Russia."
-It's totally different.
Does that sound familiar to you?
-Uh, like, it goes, "Ding, ding,
ding, diggy, ding, ding.
Ding, ding, ding,
diggy, ding, ding."
That's the way their's goes.
Our's goes, "Ding, ding,
ding, diggy, ding, ding, tch.
Ding, ding, ding,
diggy, ding, ding."
That little bitty "ting,"
it's not the same.
-Did you guys think we wouldn't
play that clip again?
Now, some of you might
be wondering, "Hey,
how can you not have the money
to play an MC Hammer sample
but you do have the money to
play an 'Ice Ice Baby' sample?"
Well, the answer is because
the "Ice Ice Baby"
is within the body
of an interview,
which means it's fair game,
and it also means
that if we had
MC Hammer on our show
and we convinced him to say
"you can't touch this,"
we'd be in the clear,
in a plan we're calling
Operation Work Around,
A.K.A.
"you can touch this."
Anyway,
what was I talking about?
Oh, right, foreign affairs.
And then the moment came
where Biden
finally met Putin face-to-face
as President,
first with an introduction
by the president of Switzerland
and then with a brief handshake
before heading inside.
-Mr. President
of the Russian Federation,
Mr. President of
the United States of America,
on behalf of
the Swiss government,
I would like to welcome you
to Geneva, the city of peace.
It is an honor and a pleasure
for Switzerland
to host you here for this summit
and, in accordance with its
tradition of good officers,
promote dialogue
and mutual understanding.
I wish you both presidents
a fruitful dialogue
in the interest of your
two countries and the world's.
Best wishes, and goodbye.
[ Camera shutters clicking ]
-Man, the president
of Switzerland
got the hell out of there
as fast as he could.
"Best wishes and goodbye"
is like the most crushing thing
you can write in someone's
high school yearbook.
In fairness, if you were
standing between
Putin and Biden,
you'd be eager
to get out of there, too.
It's like being a referee
at a Tyson fight.
"All right, gentlemen,
shake hands,
and let's have
a good, clean fight.
And if you need me,
I'll be in my car."
This summit was obviously tricky
for many reasons,
because on the one hand,
Biden wants to hold
Putin accountable
for things like cyberattacks
on critical infrastructure,
human rights abuses,
the killing and jailing
of dissidents,
and election hacking.
And he also wants to stand up
for the principles of democracy.
But on the other hand, the last
thing anyone should want
is a tense confrontation
with a nuclear armed country
like Russia.
We need accountability
and diplomacy.
Both things can be true
at the same time.
No one wants another Cold War.
For one thing, I'm not even sure
30 Rock has a fallout shelter.
And if it does,
it's probably crammed full
of old Rock Center
Christmas trees.
I mean, they can't just
put them out on the curb
like everyone else.
Also, I'm not sure
I can duck under this desk,
even if I had to.
For a while during the pandemic,
I tried sleeping under there,
but I ended up
just crashing on the sofa,
using cue cards as blankets --
cue cards Wally then
made me pay for.
-Hey, they don't grow on trees,
Seth.
-Well, they're made out of
paper. They are trees.
-You know what they say?
"Cicada," "cicawda."
What? Anyway, the two sides
also went into this
clearly aware that there was
a lot to get done
and not much time to do it.
In fact, the meeting
only lasted about three hours.
But originally, U.S. officials
said, "They expected the talks
to last four to five hours,
or perhaps longer.
The leaders are not expected
to share a meal."
"No breaking of bread,"
a senior administration official
said.
Four or five hours
without a meal?
Is this a diplomatic meeting,
or are they prepping
for a colonoscopy?
I mean, Jesus,
if I had to go that long
without so much as a snack,
even I would be screaming.
-What happened to the server?
Where is the server?
-Seriously, after four
or five hours without food,
I think I'd be ready to just say
"[bleep] it" and declare war.
For the sake of world peace,
at least get these guys some
crackers and a dip or something,
or perhaps might I suggest
some jalapeño poppers?
Only at Applebee's.
I got to get my pop on.
It's good in this neighborhood.
You could do both.
And if you thought the meeting
would be tense by the end,
it was somehow chaotic
from the start,
with reporters jostling
to shout questions
and get photos
of the two leaders
sitting next to each other.
In fact, the audio was so bad,
no one could hear them.
And at one point, a photographer
blocked everyone's shot
and refused
to get out of the way.
-Not in front of the camera.
-I'm not in front of the camera.
-Sir, can you --
Can you move because
we can't get a shot?
-I can't do this.
-I told you, go away, please.
-I can't move because --
-Go away.
Go away.
I ask you, go away, please.
-That was one of
the most anticipated
international summits in years,
and the press treated it like
an aunt taking a family picture
with her thumb over the camera.
"Jesus Christ, Deborah,
let me do this.
What is this, an Android?
Will someone answer
the damn door?"
I mean, seriously, dude,
what are you doing?
You can't just stand in front
of the camera like that.
You're supposed to be
television professionals,
and you can't even
get a clean shot?
I mean, we need to see
what's going --
Sorry.
Wally, can you -- can you
get out of the way, buddy?
Wally?
Wally, you're in the shot.
No, buddy, that's worse.
See, now you're even closer.
Wally, come on.
Wally, I know you're
doing this on purpose.
I promise next time
a guest drops out,
you can be the fill-in.
-"Cicada," "cicawda."
-What are you talking about?
Things got so chaotic,
reporters were actually
pushing and shouting,
and a lot of them
couldn't even get into the room.
-You saw how chaotic
it was there
as it was just going on,
where the reporters
and the cameras are in the room,
and you could see reporters
blocking the camera,
people talking to each other.
We're told it actually
got incredibly tense
between the two different
press corps,
which we should note are
separated on the grounds here.
We have the White House
press corps,
the American press corps,
and the Russian press corps.
And we're told there were
some combative exchanges
with the Russian press.
There was pushing
and there was shoving
trying to get into that room.
There was pushing and shoving
and yelling happening outside
as all of these reporters
were trying to get inside.
-Oh, my God, is this
a diplomatic meeting
or a Metallica concert?
These two dudes,
they're the last guys
I'd expect
to inspire a mosh pit.
Although, given his
working-class roots,
I'm guessing Joe Biden
was in his fair share
of scuffles back in the day.
This thing sounded like
a dive bar in Scranton.
I'm shocked Joe wasn't holding
half a broken beer bottle
in his hand.
"We can either head home
to our own beds
or spend the night in the ER.
Your choice."
Right before we stopped
writing this segment
so I could spend
the rest of the day
watching Finnish YouTube clips
to nail that accent,
it should be noted I haven't
been paying my YouTube bills,
so I think I got
some pretty bad video.
Both leaders held
their solo press conference.
Putin was asked
if he could achieve
a new level of trust with Biden,
and his answer was not
exactly reassuring.
-We just wonder to what extent
you have now got to
a new level of trust.
Do you think that,
at this present stage,
we can talk about a new stage
of bilateral relations?
There is no happiness in life.
There's only a mirage
on the horizon.
So, you know, cherish that.
-I guess we found a worse thing
to write in someone's yearbook.
I mean, Jesus, if I had known
that was going to be the answer,
they could have had Werner
Herzog do the translation.
"There's no happiness,
only a mirage on the horizon
as time fades away
and the clock ticks away --
ticktock, ticktock."
By the way, I could have also
done it as Christoph Waltz
and it would have been
very different.
If it was Christoph Waltz,
he'd be pulling leather gloves
off his hand
one finger at a time
while taunting James Bond
about torture.
"You will soon discover, James,
there's no happiness in life.
Only a mirage on the horizon,
yes?"
No one?
No one will back me up? Ice?
-It's not the same.
-What? Ice?
You're gonna do me like that?
This was perhaps
the most anticipated meeting
of Biden's presidency so far,
and it was
a careful balancing act,
holding Putin accountable
for his actions
while also pursuing diplomacy
instead of confrontation
with a nuclear power.
And you can tell from Biden's
expression that he was ice-cold.
They might have well played this
during the meeting.
-"Ding, ding, ding,
diggy, ding, ding.
Ding, ding, ding, diggy,
ding, ding."
-What does that even mean,
going to the well
one too many times?
This has been "A Closer Look."
♪♪
God's Love We Deliver
cooks and brings
over two million meals a year
to men, women, and children
living with HIV/AIDS,
cancer,
and other serious illnesses,
and they need your help now
more than ever.
If you're watching this online,
you can hit the "donate" button.
Stay safe, get vaccinated.
We love you.